des attentats qui ont créé un
traumatisme et engendrer un état de peur
conséquence le gouvernement va adopter
une loi qui est toujours en vigueur le
patriot act un système de surveillance
massif un texte qui limite les libertés
fondamentales et augmente le pouvoir des
agences de renseignement elle les
explications de notre correspondant
thomas bonnin
après l'émotion provoquée par les
attentats du 11 septembre 2001 les
autorités américaines veulent frapper
fort et vite quarante cinq jours
seulement après les attaques terroristes
le congrès adopte un nouvel arsenal
législatif présenté sous le nom de
patriot act une série de mesures qui
étend les possibilités de surveillance
par les agences de renseignement en
clair cela permet notamment d'écouter
les conversations de millions
d'américains sous couvert de lutte
contre le terrorisme de l'aveu même de
certains parlementaires à l'époque la
loi a été adoptée à la va vite sans que
son contenu ne soit connue du grand
public et sans véritable débat au fil
des ans le patriot act et prolongée
régulièrement par le congrès américain
et devient une nouvelle norme certains
s'offusquent déjà des atteintes aux
libertés individuelles mais leur
discours peine à trouver un écho
important finalement il faudra attendre
des affaires médiatiques d'usagé
controversé de cette surveillance ou
encore les révélations des douars
snowdon pour que le grand public le
prennent réellement conscience de
l'étendue des pouvoirs accordés aux
agences de renseignement américaines les
millions d'américains écouter dans le
cadre d'un programme secret même
l'auteur du texte de loi se dit choquée
par l'utilisation qui en est faite
en tant qu'auteur du patriot act je suis
extrêmement perturbé par ce qui apparaît
comme une interprétation exagérée de la
loi le fbi a il a invoqué pour une
décision de justice top secrète afin de
recueillir les données téléphoniques de
potentiellement chaque appel qui a été
passée par les millions de clients de
verizon ces rapports sont profondément
inquiétants et soulève des questions sur
la sécurité de nos droits
constitutionnels
aujourd'hui le patriot act a laissé la
place à d'autres dispositifs législatifs
permettant également une surveillance
accrue mais cette loi votée en octobre
2001 aura ouvert la voie à des
législations similaires dans d'autres
pays comme en france par exemple où les
mesures drastiques ont été prises après
les attentats en 2015 au point
qu'aujourd'hui aucun retour en arrière
ne semble envisageable c'est en tout cas
ce que pense le lanceur dallaire julian
assange
cela va se poursuivre c'est la réalité
de la technologie les états sont
puissants l'état profond et puissant la
technologie est difficile à gérer cela
devient moins cher cela va arriver on ne
peut pas penser en ces termes d huez sur
la vie privée et sur le droit à la vie
privée nous devons nous battre pour cela
d'une certaine façon
donc il faut se demander quelle société
cela va produire
et s'il ya d'autres mécanismes pour
contrer les conséquences sociétales qui
conduisent à l'autoritarisme au
conformisme et à l'intégration poussée
entre l'état profond et le reste de la
société
pip styles
présentés à chaque fois comme des règles
d'exception ces lois sont désormais bien
ancré dans le droit sans qu'un débat
mais jamais été réellement mener ni sur
leur efficacité ni sur leurs atteintes
aux libertés